in zusammenhang mit der zweiten england
reise 17 94 95 entstanden die sechs
londoner symphonien heidens letzte
symphonie sie bilden den krönenden
abschluss seines symphonischen werkes
hayden konnte mit einem für die
damaligen zeit übrigen orchesterapparat
rechnen vor allem der anteil der bläser
in london war beachtlich so setzt er zum
ersten mal in seinem schaffen
klarinetten ein und sieht auch die sonst
selten verwendeten trompeten vor so dass
die partitur eine komplette klassische
harmonie musik aufweist im vorliegenden
satz den zweiten satz aus der symphonie
nummer 100 spielt außerdem das
schlagwerk in sogenannter janitscharen
besetzung das ist die große trommel das
becken und die triangel dazu die
obligatorischen pauken eine wesentliche
rolle deshalb der name militär symphonie
[Musik]
[Applaus]
kaum ein anderer film hat die wirren des
zweiten weltkrieges je ehrlicher und in
so erschütternder und eindrucksvollen
bildern dargestellt als steven
spielbergs der soldat james ryan die
musik zu diesem und allen epos stammt
vom großen amerikanischen film
komponisten john williams der sein werk
den gefallenen fixierten widmet können
zur reform eine ehrerbietung an die
gefallenen danach hören wir von 7 und
anderer schick als hommage der
gardemusik an die heutige verleihung des
friedensnobelpreises das werk promise of
peace der komponist für tus
musikalischen des todes jahr von kaiser
franz joseph europa steht inmitten einer
der grausamsten kriege aller zeiten ein
zu hohes maß an unüberlegter
leichtsinnigkeit der entscheidungsträger
das damals zur eskalation dieses krieges
wohl auch entscheidend beigetragen haben
mag sie musikalisch durch die sonst so
bewunderte leichtigkeit der straßen die
wiener musik geschrieben die bucht der
grausamkeit soll in der instrumentalen
anlehnung an die sonst eben so geliebten
wäre vision klänge einen gegenpart
finden und damit an die verheerenden
schlachten an der grenze zu italien
erinnert
persönlicher kind im trier eine hymne
diese stellt ein in töne gegossenes
feierliche versprechen und eine
aufforderung zum ewigen frieden in
musikalischer form dar möge diese
musikalische aufforderung uns allen in
zukunft einen gewissen auf der begleiter
sein und der friede uns erhalten bleiben
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
neunzehnter september 1991 also vor fast
genau 30 jahren wurde in den ötztaler
alpen genauer gesagt am similaun
gletscher eine mumifizierte leiche eines
mannes gefunden der gletscher hatte nach
über 5.000 jahren einen frühzeitlichen
menschen freigegeben mit all seinem hab
und gut
der russische natur firma kurt mündl hat
das leben dieses mannes nach konstruiert
und einen film gedreht beruhender fakten
wie es damals hätte sein können otto
schwarz nahm diese dokumentation zum
anlass ein werk für symphonisches
blasorchester zu schreiben um den mann
im eis musikalisch wieder auferstehen zu
lassen der beginn steht am similaun
gletscher die eisschmelze und das
auftauchen des ice man es da es folgt
eine musikalische rückblende auf dessen
leben die jagd inmitten der wilden natur
der tägliche kampf ums überleben aber
auch die dorfidylle
gewitterwolken und unheil ziehen auf
eine fehde entsteht der man verliert den
kampf und wird aus dem dorf verband er
verletzte sich und begibt sich in die
berge um einen anderen tal zu anderen
menschen zu gelangen
entkräftet versuchte ruhe zu finden aber
seine letzte stunde schlägt er bricht
zusammen schäfer setzt ein die letzte
kraft entweicht er stirbt
es wird kälter schnee zu eis und
schließt den mann ein in mehr als 5000
jahren wird man den mann im eis finden
und er wird das ortsteil man in die
geschichte eingehen
[Musik]
es folgen nun zwei weitere musikstücke
als erstes die events kinder von julius
fucik
als julius fucik am ersten november 18
97 nachfolger von peter schipek
kapellmeister im infanterieregiment
nummer 86 wurde lagen wesentliche
lebensabschnitt die bereits hinter ihm
die schulische ausbildung das studium am
prager konservatorium die militär dings
zeit die als feldwebel beendete sowie
schließlich auch das kroatische
intermezzo in sarajevo fühlte sich wohl
erst die kompositionen entstanden die in
als einen der ersten regiments
kapellmeister in österreich ungarn
auswiesen darunter auch sein
monumentalwerk österreichs ruhm und ehre
in
sarajevo führte er mit großem erfolg
sinfoniekonzerte ein ein weiteres
tätigkeitsfeld auf dem er sich
profilieren konnte als das regiment im
jahr 1900 in die ungarische hauptstadt
budapest verlegt wurde öffneten sich dem
ambitionierten kapellmeister komponisten
weitere möglichkeiten in budapest in
standen einige seiner schönsten
kompositionen so der welt marsch die
residenz kinder und furchtlos und treu
demenz kinder widmet er dem inhaber des
infanterie gemeintes nummer 86
feldmarschall leute und julius von
danach hören sie mein lebenslauf ist
lieb und lust von josef strauß josef
strauß der jüngere bruder johannes wurde
am 22 august 18 27 in wien geboren in
seinem hauptberuf nicht musiker sondern
ingenieur erfand zb eine
straßenkehrmaschine daneben interessiert
er sich aber immer sehr für dichtung
musik und malerei er hatte allerdings im
gegensatz zu seinem bruder des vaters
verbot musiker zu werden ernst genommen
vier jahre nach dem tod des vaters
vertrat er dann zum ersten mal seinen
bruder als leiter der kapelle zwar nicht
mit der geige in der hand sondern mit
dem taktstock aber mit unerwarteten er
jetzt begann er das studium der violine
und komposition
und leitete die kapelle immer häufiger
mit großem erfolg auch zu komponieren
begannen zunächst gleichsam zaghaft und
vorsichtig wieder titel seines ersten
weiters die ersten und die letzten
beweist dann aber mit mehr mut und
schließlich mit unerhörtem erfolg
insgesamt brachte es schließlich auf
unglaubliche
283 werke darunter auch die schlager die
dorsche wein aus österreich die
sphärenklänge die polka masur die
libelle denn die lehrerin weiter und die
polka francaise feuerfest josef strauß
start am 22 juli 78 noch keine 43 jahre
alt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
als letztes musikstück in diesen burghof
konzert verabschiedet sich die
gardemusik wien unter der leitung von
landes kapellmeister oberstleutnant hans
haus mit wie kann es auch anders sein
dem radetzkymarsch
[Musik]
[Applaus]
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
ich darf mich an dieser stelle
vorübergehend verabschieden und sie in
wenigen minuten bei der ausmusterung
begrüßen dazu versuche ich sie aber
gruppenweise den platz zu erreichen
behalten sie bitte so lange platz bis
sie aufgerufen werden als erstes ersuche
ich die ehrengäste über das osttor auf
die maria theresien platz zu gelangen
bitte jetzt die ehrengäste